July 5th the new National Health Service
starts the NHS is heading for a special
anniversary it is 69 years since its
founding father nie Bevan launched what
he called the biggest social experiment
in history it is a service free at the
point of use that would Shepherd
post-war Britons from cradle to grave
the doctor should be your servant not
the state servant you should choose you
choose or change him but as the NHS
heads for 70 a service dedicated to
saving lives itself in a critical
condition hospitals up have been under
huge pressure this winter Social Care
already is in crisis it's held together
by saw the tape and brown paper I would
like to say to politicians we will not
accept the privatization of air in HS
there are going to be funding pressures
on health systems across the world
strike action has to be taken
it may sound militant but it's the only
way that people will listen
[Music]
the NHS is in trouble last winter was
the worst ever for patients with
hospitals struggling to cope the soaring
demand left thousands queuing on
trolleys and wards for almost to
capacity comes after the biggest funding
squeeze in NHS history and 7 years of
pay restraint under conservative leg
governments that has seen junior doctors
go on strike and nurses threatened to
the recent cyber hack and the remarkable
response to the Manchester terror attack
are a reminder of our reliance on a
service that the public claimed to value
above all others the Queen recognised
the commitment of NHS staff after the
attack but politicians seeking election
faced tougher questions about how they
will shape and fund the service to meet
the fundamental challenge of soaring
demand the NHS is busier than ever last
year twenty two point nine million
people were admitted to A&E but
hospitals struggled to cope and missed
the target of seeing 95 percent of
patients within four hours managing just
89 percent pressure is only going to
grow because patients are changing we're
getting older and living longer with
complex conditions which means we need
more care in hospital and when we leave
in 2015 there were 11.5 million over 65
by 2035 it will be sixteen point three
million and while demand for an H s
services is rising at three to four
percent a year funding is growing by
only one percent unless that gap closes
patients may suffer
the man currently in charge is one of
the most recognizable and controversial
members of Teresa Mays government days
earlier Jeremy Hunt has been health
secretary for almost 5 years but the
government's record is so contentious
he's facing a challenge from a doctor
representing the National Health Action
Party in his constituency and the issue
dominates local hustings Hunt's critics
say conservative policy has betrayed the
NHS he stands by his record that says
future funding depends on the brexit
deal Britain gets from Europe question
on voters Minds is which party can they
trust to actually deliver that extra
funding is it Teresa made who will keep
the economy saved by getting a good
brexit deal or Jeremy Corbyn who frankly
can't even get his own party to agree
about brexit and I think what we are
saying is now as conservatives we are
committed to the NHS committed to the
social care system and we will deliver
the strong economy I can fund it safely
going forward
how'd Southwest Surrey seat is in one of
the most affluent corners of the country
but his constituents are not immune to
ill health and share national and local
concerns I'm a cancer patient with a
very aggressive form of prostrate cancer
and I've been given extra time as a
result of the treatment that I've
received so I I find it very difficult
to criticize the National Health had two
strokes being in the Ross sorry I'm
disturbed that they're going to move
stroke unit as a child I had an
experience what it was like before the
NHS service and so remembering the GP
used to come and visit us at home and
then my mother having to pay him and
then after that you know enjoying the
benefits of the NHS the reception per
hunt is not always so polite mr. ham how
does it feel to be demolishing the NHS
this is what happened when he visited
st. Helier Hospital in Sutton threatened
with closure last month how do you feel
about that mr. ham do you sleep at night
if you want to see what the NHS means to
some people meet the locals who use the
hospital I wrote it so I'm trying to get
a message out and I want you guys to do
the same for two weeks
use your well wisely here we go well
outside but is that safe there
we did not sign up for this yeah it's
not safe not fair but they just don't
care we did that sign up for this it was
built there in the 1930s to serve the
biggest council estate in Europe at the
time that's the population it was built
so they're still there and the numbers
have probably doubled the best part
negotiating Ave with a gun to our hands
st. Helier could be closed as a result
of an NHS plan to make the most of
scarce resources by better coordinating
local services that means in some cases
that could be centralized or closed
[Applause]
there are similar plans and protests
across the country this march was
against the possible closure of
Liverpool Women's Hospital critics of
the reforms say they're an excuse for
cuts and privatization but independent
experts say the NHS has to change to
meet demand the NHS needs to be honest
with itself and the public about the
unpopular but necessary changes in
hospital care that will be required
during the next Parliament I don't
expect whole hospitals to close in most
places what we need to do is concentrate
specialist services like cancer care and
stroke care in fewer hospitals
delivering better standards because
they're concentrating on these complex
services that can't be provided for the
same standard everywhere
the food is really delicious available
for labor closures are a red line and
their health spokesman meeting
constituents in Leicester says they
would halt current plans we're not
opposed to changing services we want to
see more services provided in the
community the NHS hasn't stayed exactly
the same over its 70 years but the way
which this currently organization has
been railroaded through is that local
people haven't been involved there are
examples where local clinicians don't
agree with the various different
closures and a lot of the time Hospital
bosses have had to come up with these
plans based on a financial envelope that
isn't realistic so what we're saying is
let's just hold them let's step back
let's have a moratorium and let's review
them properly labor believe their
promise to increase NHS funding is their
strongest electoral hand and think their
concern is shared by voters we need to
be able to access it as quickly as
possible yes everybody missing longer
service notice are you a busy reception
sir I am busy and 4050 time the ring is
there the nobody because our phone from
the reception and has it gotten better
or worse what what yeah what it is noisy
they're feeling the strain in London to
this GP surgery in Vauxhall is busier
than ever but it's struggling to find
doctors because of a recruitment crisis
its senior partner its dismayed the NHS
is a strange place at the moment it's
held together by sellotape and brown
paper why do we judge everything in the
NHS by the hospital it's a National
Health Service not a National Hospital
service why are we looking at easing the
burden on A&E when the real burden is
here in general practice safety special
waiting for you over there
the greatest challenge for the NHS is
our aging population we're getting older
and living longer with complex
conditions and the older we get the more
expensive to treat
resident at hazel WellCare home on
Merseyside enjoy surroundings at a more
boutique hotel and old people's home
it's a private home where care starts at
nine hundred pounds a week that marjorie
is an NHS patient she could have been a
bed blocker a patient who can't be
discharged because they don't have the
care they need at home she was brought
here taxpayers expense to free up a bed
in hospital at least here you had
allowed your own little bit of
independence and and things like that
really we're at hospital for so busy
aren't they
you sort of left in your room or in your
ward because that the nurse has been
overstretched really with lots of work
to do so of course there's no comparison
fixing Social Care is hugely complex as
Theresa May discovered when she was
forced to reverse a manifesto placed to
abandon a cap on costs nothing has
changed nothing has changed or has
changed is that Social Care is now at
the forefront of the campaign hello
nice to see you get out are you the
Liberal Democrats a social care is a
priority and form a coalition health
minister Norman lamb has long called for
a cross-party approach how difficult is
it going to be to get away from the
political head-to-head and persuade
politicians to get out of the way of
what health service and social care sure
well it I think interestingly the very
time to do this is straight after the
election and we're saying you know
within a month of the election let's
just set up this NHS and care convention
with a sixth largest economy in the
world we're a rich country relatively
speaking we ought to be capable
of organizing an efficient and effective
and modern health and care system that
meets people's needs honesty has not
been a feature of recent political
promises about the health service if
this is a brexit election vote leave
told us the EU referendum was about the
NHS brexit ears walked away from this
pledge the day after victory but the
money would be welcomed 350 million
pounds is about what it costs to run the
NHS for a day all three main parties
have pledged more money to the NHS and
it needs it Sky News is revealed that
hospital trusts like this one are
running a combined deficit of more than
700 million pounds a figure the
government did not want released until
after the election but the truth is none
of them are offering enough to keep up
with demand that will only continue to
rise as the population grows and the
baby boom generation turns 70 that means
whoever ends up in government is going
to face major questions about how to
fund the future of the NHS but even a
blank check may not be the answer unless
we change to taking responsibility for
how we live what we can drink when we
choose to go to the doctor could have a
huge impact taking care of ourselves may
be more important to the NHS and how we
vote Paul Kelso Sky News